the mundane rant video was
reverse-engineered like it's just I just
knew that people would like want to
watch it and like and that's what I also
think is gonna happen here basically I
want this film do the audacity to
actually go out and do it you're 52
years old and it's not being talked
about enough that hey man hey gal like
it's not over if you want it so bad if
it's in you like you know maybe it's not
time to take up golf or you know pack it
in maybe it's time to actually triple
down and really focus on your 7 p.m. to
2:00 in the morning there's so many
people that truly are good entrepreneurs
or have entrepreneurial DNA but they
just weren't lucky enough to be born
during an era that that seemed practical
like it's just so like it's hard for
somebody who's for 30 years gone a
certain blueprint to understand that
this is that realistic and they feel
like it's a young man's support and it's
just not like it's just not it's you
know if you've got the right DNA and
you're a 72 year old female you have
just as good of a bad as a 27 year old
dude but you've been trained and story
told to and positioned and lived in a
50-year matter that doesn't feel like
this thing in here is a practical way to
build that but it is the
entrepreneurship is not predicated on
taking away from your family
entrepreneurship is from taking away
from everything else so stop making
excuses
oh these millennial kids are so entitled
these kids didn't have to work as hard
as we did nobody cares if you're 40 70
90 alien female male minority the market
will accept your victories if you're
good enough to have a victory and I
believe more than ever that if you're 49
year old housewife or two kids because
of this phone you've got more
opportunities to create something for
yourselves please my friends do not
allow just the 18 and 14 and 22 year
olds to grab at this pie that is so
available to all of us regardless of our
age we're going to live longer the
opportunities
real for the 58 year-old right now
that's watching us you don't live
another 40 years forty years of being
able to do something you love is a big
deal
start putting in the work start
recognizing this isn't just a young
person's game start representing start
representing the people that actually
put in the work the gray hairs that that
context that knowledge start deploying
that educate yourself on the new world
yes you didn't grow up with Instagram
you didn't grow up driving and you learn
that stop making excuses start getting
educated in the actual world and start
opening up the opportunity in my true
opinion you are actually more likely to
be successful in building a company and
forty five fifty today then the eighteen
year olds that are coming out because
there's a naivete a lack of experience
you have experience you have experience
like that's a real thing like cool like
a youth and excitement is great you have
actual business experience as a plenty
amount of talent
there's plenty amount of talent and
there's a ton of fire and bravado and
there's a confidence there's a
confidence that youth provides
difference between me and so many of you
is I've put in the goddamn work to learn
where people's attention now is and I'm
deploying myself through there many of
you have drawn a line in the sand and
say I'm not downloading snapchat
I'm not downloading Instagram and that
my friends is gonna allow you to lose
this video is made for one reason I want
it to be the calling card the seed of
the explosion of the 40 to 80 year old
entrepreneur in our society
twenty-five-year-old that feels that
they're entitled to this and then on the
flipside the diminishing just a little
bit of batches with a little smoke left
of that same entrepreneur when they were
22 at 46 when practicality and family
dynamics and the history and the market
tearing down and the lack of that same
opportunity has just window that I think
happened to a moment where they don't
believe is that they've got that shot
and I'm here to tell you you absolutely
do I mean there are absolutely a ton of
entrepreneurs that starting their
companies in their 40s 50s 60s and 70s
when it was difficult to do such a thing
City Franco Crane agree goose didn't get
this big thing into in seventies and so
I'm desperate I'm desperate to give you
the springboard to say you know what
instead of watching house of cards
seasons and instead of trying to you
know go to ball games or things of that
nature
yeah I do have 7:00 p.m. till 2:00 in
the morning
Monday through Friday hack for a lot of
you the kids are out of the house I mean
let's get into the practicality for the
way too late 40 to 50 60 year olds that
are watching this round the kids are out
of the house like yeah you can pick up
golf already you can finally start that
candle company because you put pretty
pictures of candles on Instagram and it
happens learn the craft figure out the
opportunity hand
and go attack it you only live once when
you're 90 to 100 years old and
regretting that you never build this
business and let this era pass this
moment where there's so much object or
the upside maybe read it and rent is the
worst I mean that's what it is at least
the way I see it like I got home at
midnight last night and every [ __ ]
night like it's just real like I don't
have to so I don't know I think there's
a real there's a real opportunity to to
inspire a generation that so deserves it
like I almost feel like that's being 40
I feel like I'm caught Rayna middle like
I have so much empathy for I recognize
how insane I had to be to to like I mean
you can't even imagine how not practical
being an entrepreneur was when I was
your guys it like when I was half your
age like in school like like a 15 year
old now in school that's getting DS but
it's like selling [ __ ] on the internet
everyone's like oh uh there's our next
year to the next Mark Zuckerberg mine
was like yo ho you're the next piece of
[ __ ] you know like you know like it's so
insanely different and so I have a lot
of empathy for people that I don't I
don't know if they'd recognize how real
is